we have had a very short statement in
which the palace have said the Queen and
the Duke of Edinburgh have heavy cold
and so have decided not to travel to
Sandringham today it is worth pointing
out that we wouldn't usually get a
running commentary on the health of
either the Queen or the Duke of
Edinburgh but because there were these
photographers waiting in King's Lynn at
the train station there for the royal
party to arrive and they were
subsequently told that the Queen wasn't
going to arrive it has now meant that
the palace has had to release this very
short statement confirming that yes the
Queen and the Duke of Edinburgh are
unwell at the moment so have decided to
delay their plans to travel up to
Sandringham today it's worth pointing
out that this is a really important part
of their annual calendar every year the
royal family head to North Norfolk it
really is seen as important family time
but we are still a few days away from
Christmas aren't we so they still have a
bit of time to make it to Sandringham I
think of course over the next few days
we'll be waiting for any updates on how
both of them are feeling I suspect they
will be reluctant to put that out into
the public domain because they just like
to keep calm and carry on
they very rarely like to pull out of any
public engagements because of any health
issues so I suspect we'll be waiting
over the next few days to see exactly
how they are but at the moment the
standard the royal standard is flying
over Buckingham Palace so we know that
the Queen is still in residence there we
wait to find out exactly when they'll
travel to Sandringham